[Music]
there haven't been any full-blooded
Filipino there has been to the NBA and I
just want to be the first one and I just
wanna show everyone that we can also
make it my dad always told me to watch
films of Hakeem Olajuwon Tim Duncan
those guys and I just kept watching you
know every day my dad was in the
professional leagues in the Philippines
so you know he just taught me almost
everything he knows about the game and
we always started with footwork you know
how to make easy shots you know you hear
7-foot and sometimes I mean 610 611 he's
legit seven - so it's just a breath of
fresh air to work with somebody whose
goals are so and reached but also knows
and is willing to put the work in that
it's gonna take to get there basketball
really a religion to the Philippines and
every time you go out of your house
you'll see a court here court there you
just see everyone playing basketball and
that's just how we love the sport in our
country he's definitely like a type of
battle player I'll pass like he'll look
for you he's not a selfish player you
know the mentality in the States when
you're a foreign player with hype and
accolades coming in people want to play
against you you know everybody has their
goals and everybody's trying to get on
so what better way to get recruited to a
college and saying hey I had X amount of
points and rebounds and blocks against
Kai Soto and here's Moscow him against
him I think he realizes that now and he
kind of brings it to his opponents that
are waiting for it to come to him the
first few months I'm just getting used
to like the like the culture the people
and the basketball here and I just I'm
just very happy that I have my whole
family here I didn't really know a lot
of things about college recruitment
because in the Philippines I was still
at tenth grade so I wasn't really like
focus on any college but when I came
here you know I just got a little shock
that things are happening
so fast and I just have to be ready for
it I see guys is somebody with a world
of potential and the sky is really the
limit but also you know there's a short
time to get there and has to be
deliberate and making those goals
achievable the training here in the
States is different because they really
like focused and my training really
dedicated themselves to help me get
better as a player one thing that we
wanted to really work on getting him to
be more NBA ready which means you know
can he handle the NBA pace of the game
physicality can they use this length in
a meaningful way
does he stretch the floor consistently
can he guard players can he garden the
post can he guard off switches coach
person coach Rob Jeremiah jive been
helping me a lot to helping me prepare
and I just I just get my confidence from
my workouts from my practices I think
for him to come become more physical a
lot of it's gonna take some work at p3
which he's working at every day they do
a great job kind of sports science and
strength and conditioning to develop him
off the court which i think is really
really important here at p3 we assess
our athletes we know what the needs are
so with Ty I think from from this point
on it's just a matter continue to
develop the strength develop that power
he's gonna be playing and matching up
against guys who are bigger than him so
making sure that he is able to match
that intensity on the court but also
making sure that he stays healthy too to
be able to compete year-round that was a
moment in time for him at basketball
Without Borders where all 30 NBA teams
are there there's high-level kids that
are his age that are there and he's able
to see you know I didn't make the first
team I wasn't MVP I wasn't on the first
team all camp and so what are the things
I need to do to improve and so now
you're able to look at positive feedback
from GM Scouts it was good
I do I had the opportunity to play
against the best players all over the
world and to be coached by great coaches
what are the gaps what's gonna help him
get there and I think he took it to
heart you know I think he saw kind of
where he was and was able to size
himself up a little bit and now he's
able to take a step forward because he's
grounded in reality he's not caught kind
of in the hype world you know potential
is something people talk about a lot
right potential potential potential
there's always a point though where you
have to start turning a corner and
potential assets become reality and for
him he's starting to approach that phase
and I think he understands that and so
as long as he continues to move forward
and progress it's got every every
opportunity in the world to be a good
NBA player my ultimate dream is to make
it to the NBA and I also want to
represent the Philippines on
international tournaments I just want to
show that Philippines is part of the
basketball world I appreciate those
people who follow me and my journey
knowing that all my fellow Filipinos
from my country you know supporting me
and following me and I just use it as a
motivation inspiration just to work even
harder to make them proud
[Music]